I want to show you and you're going to
need to rule us for this to draw some
corn and a theme I want to show you what
happens with something that new presents
armed units you're just a second a
lesson maybe it is really catch it what
we're going to do is think about
dividing an interval but what happens
when you don't have a positive pair of
positive numbers in the ratio but if you
just make one of them negative what
actually sort of flows out that so if I
have these slits or these you're going
to get this in the third quadrant this
is the first quadrant so we're going to
make a hole watch Cartesian now just as
the tip because I know where the
question is going to go so I'm going to
clue you into this a little bit you're
going to need some extra spaces diagram
it will not work for you if you put
these two points on the absolute fringes
boundaries of your diagram because what
you're going to end up drawing after
that will end up off the page okay so
let's use this space kind of in the
middle key on do the best you can with
scale along this because since we're
talking about ratios scale actually that
is so it's just going to make it easier
for us to work out what on earth is
going on
can you please plot these two points so
you better to try and do it nice and
accurately you've got rip a box okay now
we know what happens if you were to draw
it off the interval a B just to remind
you by the way what's the difference
between an interval and a line interval
is an interval starts and finishes have
a beginning and end where the line in
terms of river there are read objects
that kind of do both they start
somewhere and then they go through where
they called started are we call them
raised so we've got an interval kind of
invisibility between anything now we
want to divide a be in a particular race
now I'm just going to write down a ratio
first if we divided it two to five okay
just like we were noticing with the
formula sheet before right we notice the
automat is two to five is not the same
as five to two right so that means if
the order of the ratio matters then the
order of the coordinates also matters
okay so I want you to picture absolutely
just go ahead and draw with me can you
connect into a B if you haven't already
I want you to picture where you would
place the point don't actually place it
because this is not the point we're
interested in just don't you do it
visually in life where would appoint me
if you divided a be internally in the
ratio to five roughly where would you
position it I want you to think about
where it would be in your mind now once
you've got that point in your mind I
want you to recognize that if I did not
take a B a B in the ratio two to five
but instead said the interval B a in the
same ratio to five
do you recognize that even though
usually a b-and-b a are the same thing
here because there's this difference
between the numbers the direction you go
in matters doesn't it can you know a
picture where would you be if I stared
down to be a other issues you define can
you give me a verbal description where
we should place a point which one is it
closer to closer to me right so you do
like the to hear something like that
which would make this the five do you
agree so I'm on it somewhere around
there where I'm guessing okay whereas if
I had done a be like in the first place
then it would be flipped at the closer
to a so the direction in which reduce in
matters so we're going to divide
interval this time we are going to do
just a regular a beat just look okay
it's not just the convention I'm usually
right the alphabetic to order so
okay this time we're actually giving you
information in the order of operators
now second you have a rough idea of
where we will do this if it was in total
but now if I say to do it x over you'll
see this word instead okay what that
means is we're going to put that
negative time on one of these two things
okay now what's really important to you
is that we content ourselves with the
fact that actually you can do either so
what I want you to do is with the person
next to you I want one of you to put the
negative sign on the two and I want the
person next to you to put the negative
side on the five okay now on the board I
can only do one at a time okay so I'm
going to put the negative on the two and
then we're just going to walk through
and see what happens so we're going to
call this point I'm gonna call the point
eight point eight and so now first I'm
just going to launch it to my formula
okay now like I said to you before I
have a formula which eyes motherbitch
I'm more comfortable with but if you
know you're like the kind of person who
in part case you like oh thank god for
the represent I remind the reference
sheet a lot there may be a senior
interest to actually use that one but
I'm going to start off l x1 plus k x2 on
sorry or two until you drop off okay
plus that's the max pointing it directly
you can take with that so in other words
one of these things at the top one of
them has to be out of order either the
letter Z reverse alphabetical or the f1
x2 Jeroen reverse of it defending random
passenger I'll do the wives as well
i stake upon and for myself because I
don't trust myself and essentially all
I'm doing is this massive substitution
is nothing fancy TR the only way to
screw this up is by substituting
incorrectly right like people don't tend
to like they're plotting the adding or
the division wrong okay
so I'm going to go over to all of my
numbers and I'm going to identify which
ones which
which one is x1 y1 look at the way
afraid the crazy question x1 y1 is a
because it's the first point agree so
I'm just going to label out here x1 y1
that make the other guy x2 y2 and in my
ratio I've got a K to know which one is
which okay in alphabetical order so I'm
going to call this K and L or if you're
doing the other version for this K and
yourself okay now I just need to
something okay I'm going to let you have
a go at that I don't want you to draw
too much attention to the mortgage
lender part of you I'm doing different
numbers to me but let's see what we get
at the end once we supply as far as we
can go all right I'll give you two
minutes half shot right did you get
there
are you happy have you got on your
diagram as well okay now here's my
question to you what is me number one
well the external bits not too hard to
get what they call digit though doesn't
matter
it's what you get is external outside to
the inside when we order a tea and your
picture oh where am I going to be here
four to five four five to do whatever
but then you are totally over here right
that's weird the second thing is what
can these numbers mean negative 2 5 or 2
negative 5 what's going on I want you to
pick remember you did this in order in
tone up inside externally from A to B
from A to B let's look at this version
and think about what it means if you're
going a B and you say the first thing
you're going to do is negative 2 the
first thing you're going to do is
negative 2 starting from a where you go
so you've gone out right you rub but
you've gone into the reverse direction
from within each interval you've gone
this way that's the negative 2 do you
see that now you guys have the enormous
advantage of having great paper here I
hope your thing is to scale you can get
a ruler and you can measure this line
okay
I'm how many people wanted to I expect
how many people have made one grid
square equal to one unit have you done
that so it's key measure there for me
tell me what the measurement is like in
millimeters per megabit then I can work
that in got it he's got it say yeah wait
we're getting 29 did you use will you
that you you've got to pay that's why
I'm checking with it with this man use
the same scale besides that most people
did 26 million 28 35 let's call it let's
call it about 25 okay early Big B is
roughly equivalent to work I was going
on
okay that means that in this scheme
right one ratio of unit is about twelve
and a half till now thirteen ish now I
want you to think with me well where's
the five taking you
well it's positive now isn't it right to
head it back the original direction so
now I want you to just think about the
other one now because we said did you
get to a point with this did you get the
same point because the people who did it
this way yes now by the way I'm just
interested in just a decider we were
discussing but how is it they're doing
something so different ends up getting
the same thing that is interesting right
how do you interpret two to negative
five what do you think okay if there's a
true first it's a positive but the
question is told you it sticks no right
it's though so the first thing you gotta
do is get outside the word external
tells you and then if this is positive
to negative five takes you in the
opposite direction which just means up
to the first one